talk about a double standard get this
the Boston Globe won plaudits an appeal
it sir for its reporting on sexual abuse
in the Catholic Church all those years
ago and now the globe is accused of its
own scandal covering up the names of its
employees charged with sexual misconduct
the globe says the misconduct of its own
employees is a confidential personnel
matter this from the paper that argued
the public interest outweighed the
privacy of priests and seeking to unseal
evidence hypocrisy well you'll decide
joining us now with reaction from New
York is Catholic League President Bill
Donohue along with Kathy aru publisher
of Catalina magazine great to see both
of you thanks for joining us bill I know
you had a little surgery today so thanks
puffing it out with us I love it you
can't keep a good Irishman down like if
you don't come with battle battle scars
all right bill like Boston Globe says
this is a different situation this was
not a case of this this individual
employee committing any acts of physical
violence toward anyone and they cite
that as one of the reasons for the
confidentiality right they need to read
Massachusetts law Massachusetts law
defines sexual harassment as verbal as
well as physical conduct and beyond that
there are many many priests who were
charged with rather venial type of
offenses and that didn't matter at all
to the Boston Globe in fact even today
there's one of the reporters is writing
how we should make a distinction between
somebody who grabs somebody in rape
I've made that distinction now for about
15 years nobody at the blouson Globe is
willing to listen
these people are phonies they're rank
hypocrites and all of a sudden there
they discovered privacy rights and
confidentiality one standard for the
globe and one standard for the Catholic
Church Kathy well yeah but I mean two
wrongs don't make a right the church
needs to take care of its problems and
the Boston Globe needs to take care of
its problems and sexual abuse and
harassment is not okay
anywhere so the Boston Globe doesn't
need to reveal who its accused the
legend harasses
or as much as the church doesn't need to
do that the law will do that and if
these people are guilty they will be
punished and that's what we saw with the
priest that committed the crimes and
that's what we'll see at the Boston
Globe
so this employee apparently this is well
this young woman in her 20s said and she
filed this complaint back in March said
that he propositioned her to have sexual
relations with his wife but using vulgar
sexual language according to the
employee filed a complaint other sexual
harassment allegations have since
surfaced the reporter resigned okay they
declined to identify the employee
because his alleged conduct did not
involve physical to contact threats or
persistent harassment well I mean
pursuit how do you describe persistent I
mean was this one allegation was it many
allegations it seems like there were
other allegations that have surfaced
since that original allegation so
there's persistent conduct maybe not
with that one employee but there could
be a pattern or practice of this type of
conduct in the newsroom but it seems
like it's a question of whose ox is
gored here they now want the
confidentiality and they they champion
this idea of full transparency back in
2003 or 2002 right well back then they
did it because there was a definite
problem going on with the Catholic
Church and they were revealing the
problem as a media source should do as a
media should do that's what the media
does they're the watchdog of the United
States are not gonna be a watchdog they
don't want to reveal the name of this
alleged case it's an alleged we don't
know and they're not going to destroy a
person's reputation and life based on an
accusation the location you think all
the men who are accused of sexual
harassment in all these case their names
shouldn't be used their name the law
doesn't require that their names be you
know you don't ruin a person's
reputation it's America you're innocent
until proven guilty it's not a court of
law it's not it's not it's not it's not
court this is just how phony these
people are not just at the Boston Globe
number of years ago a woman a reporter
from CNN came to my office and insisted
that the Catholic Church post the names
of all the accused not anybody who's
found credibly or sub-state
cheated accusation anybody has been
accused they should put that up on the
website of the archdiocese I had it I
had the phone in my hand I picked it up
and I said miss can I have the name of
your boss and his phone number
she said why I said I'm going to report
you as sexually abusing me and then I'm
going to ask whether or not they're
gonna put your name up on the website of
CNN she said I got your point and I put
the phone down this is so this is just
as he grates me so much that you if you
want to go back to the 1920s that's what
that Boston Globe says we go back to the
1920s about accused priests well the
Boston Globe goes back to the 1870s
certainly we can go back to World War
one and I guarantee you the Catholic
League will pay for an army of lawyers
to look at the Boston Globe to see if
there's any more of this kind of stuff
going on because I don't believe them
that they rolled out a couple of cases
from the 1970s they roll out a case from
today and we're expected to believe that
that's it and they don't pay any price
for this in the law enforcement are not
engaged I've never seen such phone enos
in my life outside of Hollywood perhaps
Oh Kathy they say they've hired a lot
more women they have a lot more women
managers and that's that's insane I'm
sure can be proven but it's a medias job
to push the envelope and it sounds like
that's what they were doing with the
Catholic Church the media has to ask the
tough questions questions of themselves
you're making my point yeah fine that I
said I'm glad they exposed what they did
I'm glad they did what they did but the
question is did you let the light shine
in at home to let the light shine in if
the Boston Globe should take care of
their problems the Catholic Church
should take care of their problems I
mean there should investigate themselves
yeah find out other I'm sure all right
guys we're out of time I'm sorry we
could continue this all night